This is 99% Indusible. I'm Roman Mars. If today you pitched me the idea of the US Postal Service, there would be no way you could convince me that it could actually work. I mean, it's not perfect as it is, but the fact that you can put a 49 cent sticker on an envelope and have someone deliver it across the country in two days is amazing. Just take a second to imagine all the systems that have to work together to pull that off. So let's stipulate postal services around the world are pretty great, but with any complex design system there are failures that occur.
这里是《99%无形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。如果今天你向我推销美国邮政服务这个概念，我绝对无法相信它真的能行得通。我的意思是，它虽然并不完美，但你只需在信封上贴一张49美分的邮票，就能让别人在两天内把它送到全国各地，这简直太神奇了。花点时间想象一下，为了实现这一点，有多少系统必须协同工作。所以，我们姑且认为世界各地的邮政服务都相当不错，但任何复杂的设计系统都会出现故障。
Mail that never makes it to its destination and can't be returned to the center. And it's into this rabbit hole that producer Samara Fremark fell when she began searching for all the lost male. Once upon a time, I lost something in the male. Maybe this has happened to you. It probably has happened to you. It probably has happened to you. But what makes my story different is that I went looking for what I lost. So you didn't come here?
那些从未到达目的地且无法退回中心的邮件。制片人萨马拉·弗里马克（Samara Fremark）在开始寻找所有丢失的邮件时，就掉进了这个兔子洞。很久以前，我在邮件里丢过东西。也许你也遇到过这种情况。这可能发生在你身上。这可能发生在你身上。但我的故事与众不同之处在于，我去找回了我丢失的东西。所以你不是来这里的？
There was body. And the place I ended up was so strange, so dreamlike. Something inside the box moving. My name is Joanne Smith. But let me back up a bit. It was 2007, August. I was moving from Minnesota to Michigan to start grad school. I packed whatever couldn't fit into my station wagon into three cardboard boxes and shipped
那里有尸体。我最终到达的地方是如此陌生，如此梦幻。盒子里有什么东西在动。我叫乔安妮·史密斯（Joanne Smith）。但让我倒退一点。那是2007年8月。我正从明尼苏达州搬到密歇根州开始读研究生。我把旅行车装不下的一切东西装进了三个纸箱，并寄出
them parcel rate, books mostly. The first box arrived at the leisurely pace the book's shipped parcel rate usually do. And then I waited for weeks. The second box never showed, though when I say that it never showed, I mean that most of the box never showed. A piece of it eventually did arrive. It came in a large envelope, a neat rectangle of cardboard, the box top where I had ridden my address. Someone had taken a razor and very carefully sliced it off the box. And in close note on Postal
了它们，按包裹费率，大多是书。第一个箱子以书籍包裹费率通常的悠闲速度到达了。然后我等了几个星期。第二个箱子从未出现，虽然我说它从未出现，是指箱子的大部分从未出现。它的一小部分最终确实到了。它装在一个大信封里，是一块整齐的矩形纸板，也就是我写地址的箱盖。有人用剃须刀非常小心地把它从箱子上切了下来。而邮政
Service Letterhead informed me that my address label had become detached from my box. And so I was thrilled when I came home one day, months later, and found my third box waiting for me on my doorstep. My lost box was here. But something about the box was different. It had been torn apart and then lashed back together with plastic zip ties. When I cut it open, the cookbooks I had carefully packed were in disarray. My four-inch thick hardcovered joy of cooking had been torn apart down the spine. Like a weightlifter, I used it for some feat of strength. The two halves were sandwiched around a cookbook I had never seen before.
服务信笺上的简短说明通知我，我的地址标签已从箱子上脱落。所以，几个月后的一天，当我回到家发现第三个箱子在门口等着我时，我非常激动。我丢失的箱子在这里。但箱子有些不同。它被撕开了，然后用塑料扎带重新捆绑在一起。当我切开它时，我精心打包的食谱乱七八糟。我那本四英寸厚的精装版《烹饪的乐趣》（Joy of Cooking）书脊被撕开了。就像举重运动员一样，我用它做了一些力量展示。两半书中间夹着一本我从未见过的食谱。
Someone else's copy of Sophia Lorenz' Recipes and Memories. Sophia leared at me from the cover. Her cleavage was distracting. I was perplexed. I told my mother about it. Oh yeah, she said. that's happened to me too. She had shipped a box of books home from Europe and when she opened it, this box was filled with other people's things, all from different countries.
那是别人的《索菲亚·罗兰的食谱与回忆》（Sophia Loren's Recipes and Memories）。索菲亚从封面上盯着我看。她的乳沟很引人注目。我感到困惑。我告诉了我母亲这件事。哦，是的，她说。我也遇到过这种情况。她曾从欧洲寄回一箱书，当她打开时，这个箱子里装满了别人的东西，都来自不同的国家。
It had a Bible that was in Russian, a magazine from, I think Germany. It had some candy from the Netherlands. So it was like everyone's European vacation was in your box. from, I think Germany, it had some candy from the Netherlands. So it was like everyone's European vacation was in your box? Well, I was just astounded. My friend Helen had mailed some boxes and she had a story too. When I got the boxes open, they looked like they had been put in a washing machine and then dried. Like the boxes were so mutilated.
里面有一本俄文圣经，一本我想是来自德国的杂志。还有一些来自荷兰的糖果。所以就像每个人的欧洲假期都在你的箱子里一样。来自德国，我想，里面还有一些来自荷兰的糖果。所以就像每个人的欧洲假期都在你的箱子里一样？嗯，我简直惊呆了。我的朋友海伦寄过一些箱子，她也有一个故事。当我打开箱子时，它们看起来像是被放进洗衣机洗过然后烘干了一样。箱子被毁坏得不成样子。
And when I opened them, the box with all the food magazines, half of the issues were taken out. The rest of the boxes were all cookbook boxes, all like vintage cookbooks. And in place of that, they had put all of these southern home, southern home living whatever cookbooks from the 1980s in boxes, deviled eggs on the cover. As though that was like a reparation for my loss. Helen and my mom shrugged this off and they let things go, but it nagged at me.
当我打开它们时，装满美食杂志的箱子里，一半的期刊被拿走了。剩下的箱子全是食谱箱，都是些老式食谱。作为替代，他们放进了所有这些20世纪80年代的《南方生活》（Southern Living）之类的食谱，封面上印着魔鬼蛋。就好像那是对我损失的赔偿。海伦和我妈妈对此耸耸肩，让事情过去了，但这一直困扰着我。
Who was reading my books? Who's copy of recipes and memories was guiding me through tiramisu? And just who had switched them? Now if you ask enough questions like that, you'll find yourself in Atlanta on a day so hot the pavement shimmers. Driving past the Coca-Cola Museum, past the world's largest aquarium, past the CNN headquarters, and finally turning down the service road and pulling up in front of a non-descript suburban warehouse directly across from Six Flags amusement park.
是谁在读我的书？是谁的《食谱与回忆》在指导我做提拉米苏？到底是谁把它们调换了？现在，如果你问足够多这样的问题，你会发现自己身处亚特兰大，那里的天气热得路面都在闪烁。开车经过可口可乐博物馆，经过世界上最大的水族馆，经过CNN总部，最后转入辅路，停在六旗游乐园对面一个不起眼的郊区仓库前。
The mail recovery center. Where lost mail goes to be sorted, processed, and sent back to its rightful owner, or barring that, it's sold off. I walked up to the door for warehouse and opened it on. I bought an accessories opening bid $500. An auction. $6789, sold a pound of $151. 200 people lined up in folding chairs, waving paddles in the air. There's no live animals, there's no live weapons.
邮件恢复中心。丢失的邮件在这里被分拣、处理，并寄回给合法所有者，或者如果无法做到，就会被拍卖。我走到仓库门口并打开它。我买了配件，起拍价500美元。拍卖。6789美元，以151美元一磅的价格售出。200人坐在折叠椅上，在空中挥舞着竞价牌。没有活体动物，没有实弹武器。
And in the back, bins upon bins, hundreds of bins of lost mail. Everything that Americans have ever stuffed into a mailbox and never seen again, all sorted by type. Bins of pillows, bins of tennis rackets, bins of coffee makers, bins of stuff you can't imagine anyone ever thought it was a good idea to mail. Bins of stuff you didn't know it was possible to mail, like tractor trailer tires. And all these bins being auctioned off by officials of the U.S. Postal Service. A middle aged man sporting faded jeans, a sweat stain to baseball cap, and a handlebar mustache came up behind me, jabbing at an auction list.
在后面，是一箱又一箱，数百箱丢失的邮件。美国人曾经塞进邮箱再也没见过的所有东西，都按类型分类。一箱箱枕头，一箱箱网球拍，一箱箱咖啡机，一箱箱你无法想象有人会觉得寄送是个好主意的东西。一箱箱你不知道可以寄送的东西，比如拖车轮胎。所有这些箱子都由美国邮政署的官员拍卖。一个留着胡子、穿着褪色牛仔裤、戴着汗渍棒球帽的中年男子走到我身后，指着拍卖清单。
He was a buyer. My name's Ricky. And he was here with his wife Cindy. I mean, they got some stuff in here that's irreplaceable, like they got some vintage stuff in here from the 40s and the 50s. They've got one in there, it's got a live magazine with John F. Kennedy on it. Now how much does that work to somebody? To you, it wouldn't be worth nothing.
他是个买家。我叫里奇（Ricky）。他和他的妻子辛迪（Cindy）一起来的。我的意思是，他们这里有一些不可替代的东西，比如他们这里有一些40年代和50年代的老物件。他们那里有一个，里面有一本约翰·F·肯尼迪的《生活》（Life）杂志。现在这对某人来说值多少钱？对你来说，它可能一文不值。
To me, I can remember the day he got killed. You know, so. You've got the buttons, Kennedy for president, some of those in the... I can remember the elections. So, you know, it was just according to who you are and how much is worth to you. So you've got apparel accessories, it's clothes, it's starting bed, $500. Cameras and accessories, starting bed, $2,000.
对我来说，我记得他被杀的那天。你知道，所以。你有那些“肯尼迪竞选总统”的徽章，其中一些在……我记得那些选举。所以，你知道，这完全取决于你是谁以及它对你有多大价值。所以你有服装配饰，是衣服，起拍价500美元。相机和配件，起拍价2000美元。
Ethnic items, $500. I don't think it's ethnic item. I don't know. So what do you do with all this stuff? I was the reseller of the thing we get. That's what this thing's about. They'll be people sitting out in the parking lot on eBay before they leave here. You're kidding. They're in their cars.
民族物品，500美元。我不认为这是民族物品。我不知道。那么你用这些东西做什么？我是我们得到的东西的转售商。这就是这东西的意义所在。在他们离开这里之前，就会有人坐在停车场里在eBay上卖。你在开玩笑吧。他们在车里。
In their cars. They've got buyers waiting. Ricky and Cindy were hoping to get lucky today. As lucky as they got once, almost a decade ago, right after September 11th. We've got a whole tote of American flags. You could not buy American flag in the United States. Everything was gone. We ended up with American flag pens, American flags, everything. We had five boxes of McDonald's little arches with American flag on it.
在他们的车里。他们有买家在等着。里奇和辛迪今天希望能走运。就像他们近十年前，9月11日之后不久那样幸运。我们有一整箱美国国旗。你在美国买不到美国国旗。所有东西都没了。我们最终得到了美国国旗钢笔、美国国旗，什么都有。我们有五箱麦当劳的小拱门，上面印着美国国旗。
McDonald's didn't even have them. So we would come out smelling like a rose on that one. And just then, Gordon Plyment swept out from behind the wheel. So we would come out smelling like a rose on that one. And just then, Gordon Plyment swept out from behind the wheel of a baby blue 1960 Cadillac. Heads turned, people whispered. Mr. Gordon was male recovery center royalty. He was 80 years old with a pink face, white hair, bright blue eyes. I swear he even twinkled. He didn't seem surprised when he saw my microphone.
麦当劳甚至都没有这些东西。所以我们在那件事上赚得盆满钵满。就在这时，戈登·普莱门特（Gordon Plyment）从一辆婴儿蓝色的1960年凯迪拉克车轮后扫了出来。所以我们在那件事上赚得盆满钵满。就在这时，戈登·普莱门特从一辆婴儿蓝色的1960年凯迪拉克车轮后扫了出来。人们转过头，窃窃私语。戈登先生是邮件恢复中心的皇室成员。他80岁了，脸色红润，白发苍苍，有着明亮的蓝眼睛。我发誓他甚至在闪烁。当他看到我的麦克风时，他似乎并不惊讶。
It was almost like he was expecting me. Brooklyn, New York. Yeah. Is that where you're from? Yeah. You come all the way down here from Brooklyn, New York. Sort of. I've been on a road trip to the Pesmouth.
就好像他在等我一样。纽约布鲁克林。是的。你是从那里来的吗？是的。你从纽约布鲁克林一路来到这里。算是吧。我一直在去佩斯茅斯的公路旅行中。
Oh. So you didn't come here specifically to find out about the pot? Wait, the pot? Yeah, Jay Lennon was the last Tuesday night. Of course he was. Mr. Gordon had been buying stuff here for 10 years. He'd take his bins home, unpack them, and resell the contents. At the last male recovery center auction,
哦。所以你不是专门来这里了解大麻的？等等，大麻？是的，杰·雷诺（Jay Leno）上周二晚上提到了。当然他提到了。戈登先生在这里买东西已经10年了。他会把箱子带回家，拆开包装，然后转售里面的东西。在上一次邮件恢复中心拍卖会上，
he had bought a bin of paintings. One of them was especially pretty, an orchid in a vase. He tried to resell it at a different auction for $25, but no one was biting. So they put it back on my truck. And as they put it back on the truck, they tipped it and felt something inside the box moving. The frame was a box itself.
他买了一箱画。其中一幅特别漂亮，是一个花瓶里的兰花。他试图在另一场拍卖会上以25美元的价格转售它，但没人出价。所以他们把它放回了我的卡车上。当他们把它放回卡车时，他们倾斜了一下，感觉到盒子里有什么东西在动。画框本身就是一个盒子。
So one of the guys helping me took a screwdriver and took the back off of it. And inside was $5,000 worth of marijuana. Mr. Gordon and I sat and thought about what kind of person would send $5,000 worth of pot through the mail. And how that person must have felt when they heard about Mr. Gordon on Leno and whether they filed a claim for the painting or whether they were just relieved that the post office had lost it so absolutely that it couldn't be traced back to its original center. And then Mr. Gordon headed to the Florida bid. But first he looked deep into my eyes and he sang me a song for luck.
所以帮我的一个人拿了把螺丝刀，把它的背面拆了下来。里面有价值5000美元的大麻。戈登先生和我坐下来思考，什么样的人会通过邮件寄送价值5000美元的大麻。那个人在雷诺的节目上听到戈登先生的事时会有什么感觉，他们是为这幅画提出了索赔，还是只是庆幸邮局把它弄丢了，以至于无法追溯到原始寄件人。然后戈登先生前往佛罗里达竞标。但首先，他深情地看着我的眼睛，为我唱了一首歌以求好运。
So lament to the face, amen, lovey. In addition to being a male recovery center celebrity, he also sings mariachi at a restaurant in Alpharetta, Georgia. You belong to my heart now and forever. And into this reverie walked Lionel Snow, the director of the center, and Michael Miles, postal service representative. Who escorted me out the door? Oh, we have to go outside.
所以哀悼那张脸，阿门，亲爱的。除了是邮件恢复中心的名人外，他还在佐治亚州阿尔法利塔的一家餐厅唱墨西哥流浪乐队歌曲。你现在和永远都属于我的心。在这沉思中，中心主任莱昂内尔·斯诺（Lionel Snow）和邮政服务代表迈克尔·迈尔斯（Michael Miles）走了进来。他们把我护送出门？哦，我们必须去外面。
Told me I was violating postal service policy. You just tell me why. Shoot. Mm-hmm. Postal policy. This is Postal Policy. Yeah, but why? Do you know why?
告诉我我违反了邮政服务政策。你只是告诉我为什么。说吧。嗯哼。邮政政策。这是邮政政策。是的，但为什么？你知道为什么吗？
Well, you know, please. So I have to be like 50 feet from the center and let me across the parking lot. It is what we would clearly be prepared to talk to you about. I thought you were going to walk around in here, kind of get the ladle and see what's what. However, whatever kind of documentation that you're trying to do inside, that's where we run into a product. Okay, is it a security issue? It's security. It's a that's that's among all the issues, but yeah, security certainly is one of them. Is it because of, you know, people stuff is in there and they don't want to die? Not only that, that's not the critical issue.
嗯，你知道，请。所以我必须离中心50英尺远，让我穿过停车场。这是我们显然准备好和你谈论的事情。我以为你会在这里走走，看看情况如何。然而，无论你在里面试图做什么样的记录，那才是我们遇到问题的地方。好吧，这是一个安全问题吗？是安全。这是……这是所有问题中的一个，但是的，安全当然是其中之一。是因为，你知道，人们的东西在里面，他们不想死吗？不仅如此，那不是关键问题。
The critical issue. The critical issue is something I don't want to discuss. I mean, there's things that have been there from the early 50s. There's bodies partially, ashes and stuff that's been there for years. We would like to get things back to customers, everything. But there's something that we're unable to. This sounded, well to be honest, it sounded troubling because if the Postal Service could accidentally sell $5,000 worth of marijuana to Gordon Clement, didn't that mean that they could accidentally auction off those human remains? Ashes, yeah.
关键问题。关键问题是我不想讨论的事情。我的意思是，有些东西从50年代初就在那里了。有些尸体，骨灰，还有一些在那里放了多年的东西。我们希望能把东西还给客户，一切。但有些东西我们无法做到。这听起来，老实说，这听起来很令人不安，因为如果邮政服务能不小心把价值5000美元的大麻卖给戈登·克莱门特，那不就意味着他们可能会不小心拍卖掉那些人类遗骸吗？骨灰，是的。
Set a small woman and acid wash jeans with frazzled hair standing behind me. Her name was Jill. One part lady I know bought dishes and it had gray powder all over it. And when she finished unloading her dishes, there was all the pair of finality for somebody's memorial. It was actually somebody's ashes.
一个穿着酸洗牛仔裤、头发凌乱的小个子女人站在我身后说。她叫吉尔（Jill）。我认识的一个女人买了一些盘子，上面全是灰色的粉末。当她卸完盘子时，那是某人纪念活动的全部遗物。那实际上是某人的骨灰。
So that was funny. It was someone's ashes. Yes. On her plates? Yeah, it's all over because that was funny. It was someone's ashes. Yes. On her place? Yes, all over because it was in the bottom. I wandered around to the back of the building where postal officials were unloading bins with a forklift. Auction winners were queued up waiting to collect their purchases. One buyer was hanging to the side. My name is John Smith. My name is John Smith. I'm pretty sure that wasn't actually his real name.
所以那很有趣。那是某人的骨灰。是的。在她的盘子上？是的，到处都是，因为那很有趣。那是某人的骨灰。是的。在她的盘子上？是的，到处都是，因为它在底部。我走到大楼后面，邮政官员正在用叉车卸货。拍卖获胜者排队等待领取他们的购买品。一位买家站在一边。我叫约翰·史密斯（John Smith）。我叫约翰·史密斯。我很确定那不是他的真名。
John came to the auction a lot, he said, and he specialized in buying books. He might have bought my books once upon a time, jumbled up with thousands of others. He sympathized with my loss. He knew what it felt like, he said. It had happened to him. Yeah, let me tell It had happened to him. Yeah, let me tell you a really funny story. We shipped a case of books one time to us, we bought books,
约翰说他经常来参加拍卖会，他专门买书。他可能很久以前就买过我的书，和成千上万的其他书混在一起。他同情我的损失。他说他知道那种感觉。这发生在他身上。是的，让我告诉你这发生在他身上。是的，让我告诉你一个非常有趣的故事。我们有一次寄了一箱书给我们，我们买了书，
and we got the same box taped up. It looked like it'd been through a tornado. And inside it was a bunch of screwdrivers and pliers. There was tools inside the same box. Nothing was said. Just, here you go, here's your package. And they just replaced it with the same weight, I guess, with go, here's your package and they just replaced it with the same weight, I guess, with screwdrivers and hammers and stuff, but my
我们收到了同一个被胶带封好的箱子。它看起来像是经历了一场龙卷风。里面是一堆螺丝刀和钳子。同一个箱子里有工具。什么也没说。只是，给你，这是你的包裹。他们只是用同样的重量替换了它，我想，用螺丝刀和锤子之类的东西，但我的
books were gone. Did you ask them what happened to it? They just, what, I don't know, getting lost in the mail, I guess. The auction was still going on inside, but Ricky and Cindy, that couple who had bought that bin of American flags back in the day they were leaving empty handed. People are crazy. It must be the rich people today. People haven't got no sense in there today. Some women paid $50 for a box of VHS tapes.
书不见了。你问过他们发生了什么事吗？他们只是，什么，我不知道，我想是在邮件中丢失了。拍卖会在里面还在继续，但里奇和辛迪，那对曾经买过那箱美国国旗的夫妇，正空手离开。人们疯了。今天一定是富人。人们今天在里面没有理智。一些女人花50美元买了一箱VHS录像带。
What do you do with VHS tapes? I thought people was having money problems. I mean. Not here. There's nobody here having money problems. I mean, not here. Nobody here got money problems today. Yes. I'm leaving. I ain't nothing I can touch that I wanted.
你用VHS录像带做什么？我以为人们有经济问题。我的意思是。不在这里。这里没有人有经济问题。我的意思是，不在这里。今天这里没有人有经济问题。是的。我要走了。我没有什么可以碰的，我想要的。
So I'm going back home. I'm going to go find a lunch. First of all, we're going to go find lunch. Then we're going home. I watched Ricky and Cindy drive away. I was hot, sweaty, almost in a day, longing for home. But before I left, I turned and stood for a moment. And I watched the river of other people's things,
所以我回家了。我要去找午饭。首先，我们要去找午饭。然后我们要回家。我看着里奇和辛迪开车离开。我感到又热又汗，几乎处于一种恍惚状态，渴望回家。但在我离开之前，我转过身站了一会儿。我看着别人的东西像河流一样，
pouring out of the loading dumps, and then detrucks and moving vans. Those clothes you shipped home from college and never saw again. That fancy perfume your grandmother's wore up and down, she sent you for your birthday. The model Eiffel Tower that your dad says he air milled you from Paris. Your complete set of Southern living cookbooks, the ones with the devil degs on the cover.
从装载码头涌出，进入卡车和搬家货车。那些你从大学寄回家再也没见过的衣服。你祖母戴的那种昂贵的香水，她为你生日寄给你的。你父亲说他从巴黎空运给你的埃菲尔铁塔模型。你那套完整的《南方生活》食谱，封面上印着魔鬼蛋的那套。
All those things that you thought were lost forever, they're all here. They're all in Atlanta, across from Six Flags amusement park. And they're all in Atlanta, across from six flags amusement park, and they're all going home with someone else. And then there was nothing left to do but get in my car and drive home. And when I got home, I made eggplant parmesan. You can find a good recipe for it on page 153 of Sofia Lorenz' recipes and memories.
所有那些你以为永远丢失的东西，它们都在这里。它们都在亚特兰大，在六旗游乐园对面。它们都在亚特兰大，在六旗游乐园对面，而且它们都要和别人一起回家了。然后除了上车开车回家，什么也做不了。当我回到家时，我做了茄子帕尔马干酪。你可以在《索菲亚·罗兰的食谱与回忆》第153页找到一个很好的食谱。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Samara Freemark, originally for the KCRW program on fictional. We found out about it via the third coast international audio festival. Samara now works for American Radio Works. You can find her on Twitter at S. Freemark, that's S-F-R-E-E-M-m-a-r-k 99% invisible is Sam Green's fancourt Cole Stead Katie Mingle Avery Trouffleman and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-LW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Ark Sun, an architecture and interior's firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook.
《99%无形》本周由萨马拉·弗里马克制作，最初是为KCRW的《虚构》（Fictional）节目制作的。我们通过第三海岸国际音频节（Third Coast International Audio Festival）发现了它。萨马拉现在为美国广播公司（American Radio Works）工作。你可以在Twitter上找到她，账号是S. Freemark，即S-F-R-E-E-M-m-a-r-k。《99%无形》的团队成员有萨姆·格林（Sam Greenspan）、科尔·斯特德（Cole Stead）、凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Trouffleman）和我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心，一家名为Ark Sun的建筑和室内设计公司的办公室里制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。
We're all on Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify. And you can listen to every single episode of 99% visible and see pictures that go along with all the stories at 99pi.org. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们都在Twitter、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上。你可以收听《99%无形》的每一集，并在99pi.org上查看与所有故事相关的图片。来自PRX的Radio Tapio。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。